الذئب الذي كان في حالة من الفوضى
داخل حريق القمامة داخل
حطام قطار كان أسوأ نقاش
رأيته في حياتي في الواقع لم يكن
حتى نقاشًا ، لقد كان عارًا
، ويرجع ذلك أساسًا إلى
الرئيس ترامب
أه الذي أمضى الوقت بأكمله
مقاطعة
عدم الالتزام بالقواعد التي وافق
على الكذب بشكل
خبيث مهاجمة نجل
نائب الرئيس
عندما طُلب منه إدانة العنصريين
البيض ، طرح اسم مجموعة من الفاشية الجديدة اليمينية
المتطرفة وقال: استرجع واقف
جانباً سأتحدث عنها  من ربح المناظرة
وخسر المناظرة ولكن يمكنني أن أقول لك
شيئًا واحدًا مؤكدًا أن الشعب الأمريكي
فقد
الليلة لأن ذلك كان مروعًا ،
لقد أخرجت الكلمات من فمي فقط
أم أنك استخدمت بعض اللغة السامية
سأقولها فقط
كما لو كان ذلك عرضًا هراءًا
وأنت تعلم أننا على الكابل يمكننا أن نقول إن
الاعتذار لكونك
فظًا بعض الشيء ، لكن هذه في
الحقيقة هي العبارة التي أتلقى
المزيد مما تعرفه من الأشخاص على كلا
الجانبين  o الممر
نص n وهي العبارة الوحيدة التي يمكنني
التفكير فيها لوصفها حقًا
ولا يمكنني أن أتفق معك أكثر من
ذلك ، لكن الأشخاص
الذين تأثروا أكثر من هؤلاء هم
الأشخاص الذين
يتطلعون بصدق لمعرفة ما
يمثله كل مرشح  ومن
يجب أن يصوتوا له ، لا يزال
هناك أشخاص لم
يتخذوا قرارًا بشأن أي مرشح
يصوتون له
أو ما إذا كانوا سيصوتون ولست متأكدًا من
ذلك بشكل خاص فيما يتعلق بالنقطة الأخيرة
أن هذا
الأداء والمسرح  هناك برنامج تلفزيون
الواقع ، سيساعدهم برنامج تلفزيون الواقع السيء
في أقل تقدير ، نعم ، أعني أنها كانت
كارثة كاملة على
جميع الجبهات وأعتقد أنك إذا جئت إلى
هذا التفكير
أنك تعرف رجلين في السبعينيات من العمر
يريدان أن يكونا.  يمكن لزعيم العالم الحر
للسنوات الأربع القادمة
أن يكون لديك تبادل معقول للأفكار
التي خرجت من هذا النقاش معتقدًا
أن هذا غير ممكن
لأنك بالكاد تستطيع سماعها
في نقاط معينة كان هناك الكثير من
الحديث المتبادل
واحد على الآخر ولكن جيك كما
أشرت يجب أن نكون واضحين حقًا
هنا هذا
ليس أه كلا الجانبين نوع من الوضع
كان هناك طرف واحد في تلك المرحلة
يقاطع
الصراخ على الوسيط
ومنذ البداية أعتقد أن ما كان
مذهلاً جدًا
كانت المشاهدة هي أن هذه النقاشات عادة
ما تُبنى وتُبنى وتُبنى حتى النهاية ،
بدأنا عند 12 على مقياس من 1 إلى
10.
كان الرئيس حقًا كما تعلم ،
أعتقد أنه كان في حالة هياج للغاية في
وقت مبكر جدًا من المناقشة و
تم ضبط النغمة من ذلك 2 لقد سمعت
بالفعل من أشخاص يؤيدون كثيرًا
الرئيس
يريدون منه أن يقوم بعمل جيد ، آه لأن هذا كان
يحدث لكنه
كان حارًا جدًا لدرجة أنهم كانوا يعلمون
أنه سيكون عدوانيًا كما عرفوا نحن  تحدثت
عنه مسبقًا
أنه سيحاول أن يكون في حالة
إهانة قدر الإمكان ،
لكن هذا استغرق الأمر بعيدًا جدًا حتى بالنسبة إلى دونالد
ترامب ،
فقد انتقدت
نائب الرئيس مرارًا وتكرارًا لأنه لم
ينادي على وجه التحديد منظمة أنتيفا
وغيرها من اليساريين
المتطرفين  مجموعات IST ولكن هل أنت على استعداد
الليلة
لإدانة العنصريين البيض
وجماعات الميليشيات
والقول إنهم بحاجة إلى التنحي
وعدم
زيادة العنف في عدد من هذه
المدن كما رأينا في
كينشا وكما رأينا في بورتلاند ، أنت
مستعد ، دعنا نفعل ذلك ،
أود أن أقول إن كل ما أراه تقريبًا
من الجناح الأيسر
وليس من اليمين.
هل تريد أن
تناديه
ماذا تريد أن تناديه أعطني
اسمًا أعطني مفاجأة بيضاء توقف
واقف جانباً ولكن سأخبرك
بما سأخبرك به ما الذي يجب على شخص ما أن
يفعله حيال أنتيفا واليسار
لأن هذه
ليست مشكلة يمينية ، فإن أنتيفا العنصري الأبيض
اليساري هو فكرة وليست منظمة حصلت عليها ، هذا ما قاله مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الليلة ، مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ،
أنت تعرف جيدًا ما لا لا ،
لقد انتهينا يا سيدي.
تخبرك إدارتك
بالحقيقة هل لديها فكرة سيئة  هل يمكنني أن أخبرك بما
ليس لديك
فكرة أن أنتيفا تشكل خطرًا ،
فأنت تحصل على الكلمة الأخيرة جيدًا ، من الصعب
الحصول على أي كلمة مع هذا المهرج ،
عفواً ، دعني أقول لا ،
أنا السيد الرئيس
ولهذا السبب فعل ذلك  تستحق ثلاثة
ملايين ونصف من موسكو ،
انظر هنا الصفقة التي نريد التحدث
عنها عن
العائلات والأخلاق لا أريد أن أفعل
ذلك ،
أعني أن عائلته يمكننا التحدث عنها
طوال الليل ، عائلته غير
صحيحة ولا تريد ذلك  تحدث
عما تحتاجه أنت الشعب الأمريكي
يتعلق بك هذا ما نتحدث
عنه حسنًا هذه النهاية
هي نهاية الجزء الذي
نتحرك فيه ولم يأخذهم نائب
الرئيس والإجابة على السؤال هي لا  أوكرانيا
لا ، يا سيدي بمليار
دولار أنت تعرف تمامًا ما الذي
تنتظره وأنت تفعل ذلك ،
ستكون على
ما يرام صحيحًا
لماذا لا أكون مختلفًا عنكما ،
لذا فهذه هي النقطة الجيدة
نحن  لدينا ستة أجزاء انتهينا من هذا
الجزء سننتقل إلى الجزء التالي  مقطع في
هذا الجزء ، سيحصل كل منكما على
لحظتين متواصلتين في هاتين
الدقيقتين المتقطعتين السيد الرئيس ، يمكنك
قول
أي شيء تريده ، سأطرح
سؤالاً حول العرق ، لكن إذا كنت تريد
الإجابة عن شيء آخر ،
فابدأ  أعتقد أنه سيكون من
الأفضل تقديم خدمات للبلد
إذا سمحنا لكليهما بالتحدث مع
عدد أقل من الانقطاعات.
من سيدي ليس أقل مما لديك
دعنا نواصل